part of the problem i have with the  medical community when you go in there  you're diagnosed they tell you your only  hope is us your only hope are these  medications and there's nothing you can  do about it and it's not your fault and  so it takes all the responsibility away  from yourself for fixing it because  you're like i can't the authority  figures that know what they're doing  they went to school told me that i can't  and i think if they'd just been like  can't help good luck then i would have  been like oh [ __ ] i have to figure this  out myself and i would have gone through  all these paths like diet exercise i  just would have looked